okay willkommen zur heutigen Session
ähm in dieser Session werden wir weiter auf
die philosophische Bedeutung
von künstlichen neuronalen Netzen eingehen
und zu diesem Zweck
honorieren wir zunächst einen kurzen Überblick
über die Entwicklung ähm von der Entwicklung
eines Geistes bis zur Modellierung eines Gehirns Sie
erinnern sich sicherlich an dieses Zitat
von Robert  treifus und anno erzählst du
uns etwas über diese
entwicklung und kannst zu diesem zweck
deinen bildschirm teilen
ähm ich wollte nur
einen rückblick oder einen rückblick auf das seminar und die
entwicklung unserer
ansätze zur KI-forschung
gibt es eine KI  Forschung ist ein sehr
technisches
Gebiet,
es ist bereits ein sehr altes Gebiet, es
verbindet sich mit biologischer Forschung, es
verbindet sich mit philosophischen Fragen, es
verbindet sich mit technischen Fragen im
Bereich der
Informatik,
und wir begannen mit einer sehr spezifischen
Frage, einer sehr philosophischen Frage
und dem  Die Perspektive auf diese Art von
Forschung hat
sich, glaube ich, in den letzten Wochen in dem
Text, den wir diskutiert haben, verschoben
also fingen wir mit turing an und bezogen
turing auf
searle und in diesem zusammenhang war völlig klar,
dass es für cyril eine entscheidende frage gibt,
nämlich die frage, ob eine maschine
intelligent ist
und in gewisser weise
der turing-text schon im
vorfeld bestritten, sagen wir, den sinn von bestritten hat
die Frage, ob eine Maschine
als solche intelligent ist
und versucht, eine andere Art
von Einstellung zur Beantwortung von
äh und oder
für eine andere Frage zu beschreiben, nämlich die Frage,
in welchem Fall wir eine Maschine als intelligent
bezeichnen würden, unabhängig
davon, ob sie als solche intelligent ist oder  nicht
so hier in dieser ersten
sagen wir mal konstellation rund um die ai-
forschung und ihre theoretischen reflexionen
die frage was eine intelligente maschine
ist bzw.
basierte
Bedienung
mit Symbolen der Turing-Maschine und einem
sehr spezifischen Verständnis des Denkens,
aber
und das ist der Punkt dieser Art von
Quot  Von der Gedankenbildung bis zur Modellierung eines
Gehirns und das ist sehr entscheidend für die
Frage, ob bei der Beobachtung von
Typhus in den 80er Jahren
etwas passiert ist, hat sich
auf dem Gebiet der aiia-Forschung selbst etwas entwickelt,
nämlich es gibt ein anderes Paradigma, das bereits
sehr alt ist
auch
spätestens in beginnen  den 50er Jahren und
gewann an
Dynamik, sagen wir in den 80er Jahren,
und diese neue Art von Paradigma, die heute
so entscheidend ist,
ist mit einer anderen Art von Maschine verbunden
, sagen wir,
mit künstlichen neuronalen Netzen,
die von der neurologischen Forschung im
menschlichen Gehirn
und dieser Art
von Forschung inspiriert sind  ist sehr stark verbunden mit einer
anderen perspektivischen theoretischen
Perspektive oder Perspektive der
Interpretation dieser Art von Maschine, nämlich
es wird viel weniger beantwortet, ob diese
Maschine intelligent ist oder ob er sie in diesem Zusammenhang intelligent nennen würde, sondern
vielmehr die Frage, ob
sie das Gehirn modelliert
yeah also es ist eine frage des modelns
also
der ausgangspunkt hier und das war
schon zuletzt für smallinski ausschlaggebend  Woche
ist
eine spezifische Konstellation von sagen
wir Unwissenheit ja wir wissen nicht genau wie
das Gehirn funktioniert wir wissen einiges
über das Gehirn und wir
bekommen immer mehr Wissen über das
Gehirn aber wir verstehen es immer noch nicht
ganz wir sind weit
weg davon,
und wir haben Maschinen, die
von dieser Art von Gehirnen inspiriert sind, von unserem Wissen
über Gehirne, die wir
verstehen, ja, wir verstehen die Maschinen, das ist eine
offene Frage, aber wir können sie als eine
Art Modell für das menschliche Gehirn verwenden, also haben wir
es drin  Ein Weg, zwei
Seiten der Unwissenheit, das menschliche Gehirn, das
wir nur teilweise verstehen, und
bestimmte Maschinen, die
vom menschlichen Gehirn oder von
Mem von anderen Arten von Gehirnen inspiriert sind, die
wir möglicherweise gerade nicht genau verstehen,
aber heute ziemlich gut funktionieren
zumindest
und wir können wissen, dass wir sie als
Modell für das menschliche Gehirn verwenden können, also versuchen wir in gewisser Weise
,
das menschliche Gehirn besser zu verstehen und
gleichzeitig die
Maschinen, die von ihnen inspiriert sind, besser zu verstehen  m,
aber das ist eine Frage der Modellierung
und das war die Frage, die
für
äh Smolensky entscheidend war, die für Kognitionswissenschaftler entscheidend ist
und die
auch für viele Menschen,
die in diesem Bereich arbeiten, entscheidend sind, wenn sie manchmal
theoretisch über KI-Forschung über
Deep Learning nachdenken
sind mehr
Kognitionswissenschaftler manchmal sind
sie viel mehr
viel mehr Philosophen
das sind glaubwürdige Unterschiede sehr
oft auf diesem Gebiet
und ein Beispiel für
diese Art von
Frage nach der Modellierung
eines Gehirns
mit Hilfe spezifischer Maschinen,
inspiriert von der neurologischen Forschung über
das Gehirn für diese Art  von der perspektive
finde ich sehr sehr interessant
repräsentativ cameron buckner
er arbeitet in den usa
ich glaube er ist ein ziemlich junger forscher
und er ähm
und er
hat sehr unterschiedliche artikel veröffentlicht
die
sehr
, sagen wir, sehr viel mit der heutigen KI-forschung in kontakt stehen
und versuchen, sie zu verbinden  mit
Fragen der Kognitionswissenschaften,
wie wir das Gehirn und es verstehen können  s
Performances
und mit Philosophie,
so
insbesondere in einem sehr interessanten Text
Empirismus ohne
Magie, versucht
er die These aufzustellen, dass
es uns in gewisser Weise hilft,
ein sehr altes Problem,
das mit dem Empirismus verbunden ist, besser zu verstehen, wenn wir heute bestimmte neuronale Netze verstehen  im
18. Jahrhundert und dass wir dann, wenn
wir die Maschinen und ihre
Leistung verstehen, das
philosophische Problem auf eine Weise des
18. Jahrhunderts lösen können, also verbindet er wirklich die
Philosophie der Kognitionswissenschaften
und
eine tiefe Auseinandersetzung mit dem aktuellen Stand
der Forschung auf dem Gebiet der  künstliche
neuronale netze
so aber die grundperspektive
ist die
modellierung des gehirns
und
was bei
buckner und dem text von heute und den
anderen texten von buckner interessant
ist, ist,
dass
er nicht bei der allgemeinen behauptung halt macht,
dass man das problemlos kann  kann zum Beispiel machen,
Sie können nur sagen, ähm, künstliche neuronale
Netze modellieren den Rahmen, aber wenn
Sie diese Art wirklich ausnutzen wollen  d des
Ansatzes Sie müssen konkret werden
Ja, Sie müssen sagen, Sie müssen
spezifizieren  was für eine leistung des
menschlichen gehirns nein
und vor diesem hintergrund
interessierte sich cameron buckner sehr für
eine bestimmte art von künstlichen neuronalen
netzen
und das nennt man
ähm
convolutional neuronal networks
das ist ein bisschen
in einigen bereichen der künstlichen
intelligenz oder  Maschinelles Lernen oder genauer
gesagt Deep Learning,
das
in den letzten zehn Jahren ein wenig boomte.
Diese spezielle Art von Netzwerk
aus künstlichen neuronalen Netzwerken war
in den letzten
10 Jahren möglicherweise am erfolgreichsten. Ich würde sagen,
dies ist eine Darstellung eines Skiartikels
und  andere
von 2012, denke ich,
und
was war,
was berühmt wurde für
diese spezielle Art von Netzwerk, diese
spezielle  ic
Art der Implementierung
für
äh Gewinnen ähm eine Art Wettbewerb
ein Wettbewerb, den es
schon seit vielen Jahren gibt und bei dem es
um die Erkennung von Objekten in einer
Datenbank mit fotografischen Bildern
namens Imagenet geht, und deshalb wurde dieser
Wettbewerb
auch Imagenet genannt und diese Art von
neuronalem Netzwerk  gewann 2012 und seitdem glaube ich,
dass es
diese Art von Feld mehr oder weniger dominiert.
Heute gibt es einen neuen Trend namens
Transformatoren, aber für etwa 10 Jahre
würde ich sagen, dass konvolutionelle neuronale Netze
in vielen Kontexten völlig dominierten
und die Aufmerksamkeit
vieler, vieler, sehr auf sich zogen  leute
, deshalb möchte ich
und diese art von netzwerk steht auch im
fokus des textes von buckner und anderer
texte von buckner und ich
möchte euch nur eine kleine technische äh
einführung in diese art von netzwerk geben, die
diese art der darstellung
ist
ziemlich abstrakt
und es gibt Ihnen möglicherweise keine
Ahnung, was hier passiert,
und ich möchte Ihnen zumindest
eine Art
intuitives u geben  Um zu verstehen,
was in dieser Art von Netzwerk passiert,
und in erster Linie ist es notwendig,
zwei Operationen oder zwei
Arten
von Teilen in diesem Netzwerk zu unterscheiden,
und die eine heißt Faltung und
die andere Pooling,
und ich versuche zuerst
, Ihnen eine Vorstellung davon zu geben
Faltung
Faltung ist
mit dem verknüpft, was wir Filter oder Kernel nennen,
und das ist eine sehr einfache Sache, sie wird
zur Manipulation von Bildern verwendet, und in
vielen, vielen anderen Bereichen ist
es nur
die folgende
Art von Berechnung,
Sie haben hier so etwas wie ein Bild, in
das es
direkt übersetzt wird  Zahl hier
ist eine Graustufenform
und Sie können
diese Art
von Pixelmatrix einfach durchgehen
und mit
einer Matrix multiplizieren, die Sie willkürlich definieren,
sodass Sie nur Zahlen haben. Hier gibt es
Graustufenzahlen für dieses Bild,
und dann können Sie es mit
verschiedenen Arten multiplizieren  von Matrizen jetzt
ähm einen Moment
es funktioniert nicht
einen Moment
[Musik]
das Ergebnis ist hier Entschuldigung dafür, dass
ich ein bisschen irr war  Itated, das ist nur
das Graustufen-Originalbild und das
Originalbild als Bild,
und dann multiplizierst du
äh
Quadrate
drei
ähm Vielfaches drei
drei mit den Kanten multiplizierst du es
mit dem Kernel,
der nur Zahlen sind, und dann bekommst du so
etwas wie das Original
Bild links
hast du hier den Kernel du machst diese
Art von Multiplikation und dann bekommst du
äh
anders ein anderes Bild
jede Multiplikation mit einem Kernel und
neun Punkten im Originalbild ergibt
einen neuen Punkt der auf der rechten
Seite angezeigt wird  ist sehr hell
hier ist es sehr dunkel
und du machst das zeile für zeile das ganze
bild
und dann bekommst du so etwas
hier auf der rechten seite
und es scheint sofort klar zu sein,
dass das nur rechnen
ist, nur zahlen knacken, aber
gleichzeitig  Es scheint offensichtlich einen
bestimmten Aspekt hervorzuheben, hier ist so
etwas wie die horizontalen Kanten, die Sie
kennen,
und dies wird als Tops bezeichnet. Nein,
Sie können es mit einem anderen multiplizieren
Kernel und dann bekommst du, was richtige Sobel
sind,
also ist jetzt hervorgehoben, was die
richtigen Silben sind,
oder du kannst verwischen,
du kannst versuchen, einen Umriss zu konstruieren,
und
und ähm,
es scheint zu sein,
oder ich finde das sehr interessant und sehr
faszinierend, weil es einfach so ist
Multiplikation oder viele
Multiplikationen, um ernst zu sein, aber
dennoch hat das
Ergebnis eine bestimmte Bedeutung, es scheint,
bestimmte Merkmale des Bildes zu extrahieren,
nein,
und dieser
Kern oder dieser Filter
ist
ein entscheidender
Teil eines konvolutionellen neuronalen Netzwerks,
denn was Sie hier zum Beispiel tun, wir
Haben Sie ein Bild
mit drei
ähm drei verschiedenen Kanälen für die
drei Grundfarben RGB,
also wählen wir für das Bild ein Bild mit
Pixeln zu 224 Pixeln und drei Kanälen
für die drei Farben aus,
und dann wenden Sie beispielsweise einen
Kernel
an  das rechte silber
wendet man einen anderen kern für die linken
silben an und man kann das mit vielen
vielen
kernen machen
in diesem
fall hat jemand entschieden oder krishevsky und sein
g  roup hat entschieden, dass sie 96
Kernel verwenden und jeder Kernel
vermutlich eine bestimmte Information extrahiert, bestimmte Merkmale extrahiert,
und was Sie danach tun, ist,
die Größe des Bildes des Ergebnisses zu reduzieren,
also war das Ergebnis hier offensichtlich 55 zu
55, und dann nehmen Sie etwas  wie
das Maximum von jeweils zwei kreuzen zwei
Quadraten
, das als maximales Pooling bezeichnet wird, und dann haben Sie
eine Größe von 27 bis 27,
und was Sie hier in einem Faltungsnetzwerk tun,
ist, dass
Sie mit Kernels multiplizieren,
dann reduzieren Sie die Komplexität durch so
etwas wie maximales Pooling oder durchschnittliches
Pooling  und dann können Sie wieder
Faltung oder Multiplikation mit
Kernel und Filtern verwenden, die Sie einen Schritt
nach dem anderen ausführen,
und am
Ende haben Sie etwas, was
eine vollständig verbundene Schicht genannt wird,
und das endet schließlich mit
der Ausgabe und mit einer Schätzung dessen,
was kann
Im Bild identifiziert werden kann,
gebe ich Ihnen ein Beispiel, das
sehr schön visualisiert ist. Dies ist ein trainiertes
Faltungs-Neuronales Netzwerk für die
Erkennung  von handgeschriebenen Zahlen und
was Sie hier tun
können
Sie können eine Zahl zeichnen
und dann sehen Sie hier
die Eingabe.
Dies sind die ersten
sechs
Kernel. Deshalb haben Sie
Transformationen der ersten Bilder
die Größe jedes
dieser Bilder
und dann haben Sie eine weitere
Faltung
und Sie haben weitere weitere Poolings,
Sie haben
schließlich eine vollständig verbundene Ebene, und in
der Ausgabe, die
Sie hier sehen, haben Sie die Schätzung,
dass es eine Eins ist,
nein, und die zweite Vermutung,
die ähm die ist  Die zweite wahrscheinliche Ausgabe
wäre eine Neun,
also sehen Sie hier sehr schön visualisiert,
was in einem solchen Faltungsnetzwerk passiert.
Es sind
Faltungen oder Multiplikationen mit
Filtern und Kerneln.
Reduzierung der Größe und Komplexität
reduzieren in gewisser Weise das, was diese
Faltungen
auf einer visuellen Ebene aus der
Eingabe
auf eine bestimmte Ausgabe auf eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit reduzieren  dafür sind
die möglichen Ausgaben in diesem
Fall nur 10 Ziffern, also müssen Sie
am Ende 10 mögliche Ausgaben haben,
was viel komplizierter sein kann, wenn Sie
Tiere und Bilder oder
ähnliches erkennen möchten,
aber die Grundidee ist genau
diese  Frage arno uh
ein Teilnehmer fragte uns, könnten Sie
erklären, was ein Kernel ist, wie können
wir die Funktion eines Kernels
verstehen?
quadrat drei kreuz drei in diesem zusammenhang
also hast du diese neun pixel hier
ich hoffe du siehst das dieses rot
dieses rote quadrat links auf dem linken
bild
hast du dieses rote quadrat und du
multiplizierst es
jedes pixel mit dem oder du multiplizierst
das a  quadrat aus neun pixeln
mit dem kern
und dann bekommst du ein
pixel auf der rechten seite dieses ganz
schwarze hier dann verschiebst du
das quadrat und die neun pixel im
originalbild multiplizierst du wieder mit witz
h derselbe Kernel, Sie erhalten ein zweites Pixel,
dann bewegen Sie sich wieder eins nach rechts,
und möglicherweise können Sie auch zwei verschieben, oder
das hängt von der spezifischen
Konfiguration ab,
dann erhalten Sie ein drittes Pixel, und Sie können
Pixel für Pixel verschieben, und Sie erhalten wieder und
wieder ein Ergebnis
und der Kernel
ist nur diese feste
Matrix,
die
hier im Originalbild mit jedem möglichen Quadrat multipliziert wird. Okay
, das wäre
ja, das ist Zahlenkram,
aber sicher ist es entscheidend,
was die Filter sind, wie Sie die
Filter hier angeben  In diesem Fall definiere ich nur
etwas, ich kann es
hier willkürlich auswählen
,
aber ich muss wissen, was ich auf eine Art und Weise verwende
Fenster,
aber im Fall eines Convolutional
Neural Network ist der Punkt, dass Sie
die Filter nicht von Anfang an von Hand spezifizieren,
sie sind das Ergebnis des Lernens.
Ja,
das ist entscheidend,
also ist das, was Sie tun,
wenn Sie das Netzwerk trainieren
Sie hoffen, die Filter so zu spezifizieren
, dass sie lernen,
was entscheidend ist, um zum Beispiel
Katzen in Bildern zu identifizieren,
damit die Kernel das Ergebnis eines
Trainingsvorgangs sind, sie nicht durch
die Modellreihenfolge vom Programmierer vorgegeben werden,
damit das Netzwerk lernen soll
Auf welche
Merkmale Sie
auf dem Bild achten müssen, um etwas zu erkennen
,
wofür wir es trainieren, wissen Sie,
und was dann interessant ist, ist, ob Sie ein
solches Netzwerk trainieren
und ob es funktioniert, damit Sie einfach überprüfen können, ob
es wirklich Katzen erkennt
und ob es erkennt  Katzen, dann
wäre es interessant zu schauen
oder zu untersuchen, wonach gesucht wird,
was die Kernel sind, die das
Ergebnis eines Trainings waren,
und dass
Sie dies tun können.
Dies ist ein Papier von 2014
die
Kernel suchen nach
was die Faltung
in gewisser
Weise ausgelöst wird durch
was sind die Aspekte in den
Bildern, die hilfreich sind, um Ihre Katze zu identifizieren,
und dann erhalten Sie Bilder wie
diese oder
lesen Sie mehr  In den jüngsten Arbeiten zu diesem Thema
von Chris Oola und
anderen versuchten sie eine viel ausgefeiltere Art der
Visualisierung, die versucht zu zeigen,
was die Faltung
im Bild zu identifizieren versucht
und welche Arten von Merkmalen extrahiert werden
und zur
Identifizierung von Objekten beitragen  die
Bilder
und was ist eine Art allgemeine
Beobachtung, wenn Sie dies tun, ist,
dass es am
Anfang eines konvolutionellen neuronalen
Netzwerks wirklich grundlegende Merkmale gibt
, die extrahiert werden, so etwas wie
Silben
horizontale Silben vertikale Silben,
und dann
gibt es eine Art Abstraktionsprozess,
es wird immer mehr  Es ist kompliziert, es
fängt an, bestimmte verschiedene Arten von Sobels zu
bestimmten Arten von Formen zu konfigurieren, und dann wird es
immer abstrakter
und es wird mehr und mehr objekthaft
, sagen wir mal,
und diese Art von Performance ist meiner Meinung nach
entscheidend für die Erweiterung
von Cameron Buckner
diese Art von abstraktem Prozess
, der hier in dieser Art von
Kommunikation durchgeführt wird  putation
, die im fokus von cameron
buckners ansatz steht, das wollte ich vorstellen
, wissen sie, ich bin kein informatiker,
aber ich hoffe,
es war zumindest nicht zu
unverständlich, sie haben eine ahnung, wie
das funktioniert
, haben sie fragen
dazu  In Bezug auf diese Einführung
würden wir sonst mit den Fragen zum Text fortfahren.
Ich denke, wir
können die Diskussion danach führen, weil
ich die Sitzung aufzeichne, also vielen Dank,
also jetzt werde ich meine
Folien teilen und
mit den Schlüsselfragen
für die heutige fortfahren  Sitzung, also haben
wir zuerst die Schlüsselfragen ein wenig geändert,
weil wir auch einen anderen Text im
Sinn hatten, in Bezug auf die
äh-Fragen, die wir Ihnen geschickt haben. Wir hatten
alle anderen Texte im Sinn, also denken wir,
dass diese drei Schlüsselfragen, die
wir jetzt präsentieren  sind ein bisschen
besser auf den Text anwendbar, den wir herumsenden,
also ist die erste Frage, was
die Hauptmerkmale von Deep Convolutional
Neural Networks DC und Ends sind und wie
sie sich auf ihre beziehen  technologische
vorläufer
die zweite frage ist,
was die gründe für den erfolg von
dzns sind und wo ihre grenzen liegen
und die dritte frage ist, wie verhält sich ai
supervising learning zum
lernen menschlicher lerninhalte was
spricht für eine enge beziehung was
dagegen spricht so wie wir es sehen  hat
in gewisser Weise mit Empirismus
und auch mit Abstraktion zu tun, also ist es auch eine
psychologische lernpsychologische
Aufgabe und auch eine philosophisch-empirisch-
philosophische Aufgabe,
also werden
wir jetzt
drei Gruppen und Breakout-Sessions bilden,
also schauen Sie sich diese
Fragen noch einmal
an  die Folien
und jetzt werde ich die Aufzeichnung stoppen und
dann können wir diese Fragen besprechen